ça fait du bien
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
l'eau l'eau est le principal constituant
de notre organisme
le corps d'un adulte en contient 65 %
sous les 70 kg qui s'affiche à chaque
matin sur la balance il y a 45 kg d'eau
ce liquide nous est vital il y en a dans
tous nos tissus jusque dans nos dents
mais comme nous sommes de véritables
passoires
toute cette horreur en effet sous forme
du régime de transpiration y compris
dans l'air que nous expire on est bien
me devons refaire le plein en permanence
2 litres par jour à demi litre dans la
nourriture et le reste en buvant une
douzaine de verre d'eau comme celui ci
de la bonne eau du robinet on n'a pas
tous cette chance à votre santé et je
vous le souhaite très sincèrement et à
demain et surtout n'oubliez pas nous
sommes tous confinés
mais en restant lire si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain